hello I'm Provincial Police Ronnie from
Spain I'm meeting the greatest telecom
global services responsible for Liberia
spain and portugal and latin america and
i choose to answer the question of what
can be done to improve on foster Latin
America question and unity from my point
of view and what we are trying to do
managing our company is to have global
centers in Latin America without some in
Brazil Colombia Argentina at this point
we are also trying to promote osmosis
between the Latin America countries just
to avoid centralized country operations
and trying to share services from one
continue the others that across cultural
knowledge from despair economies and
despair knowledge and is really working
very well we are starting to have a real
Latin America community our company so
ha